bonjour joëlle melin bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct ce
matin sur rtl france alors avant de
commenter l'actualité politique du jour
j'ai une question sur sur les régionales
on le voit le rassemblement national a
plutôt le vent en poupe dans les
sondages
à quoi tient ce succès selon vous alors
je vous préviens vous avez une minute 32
précisément pour répondre aux temps de
parole du csa et bien le succès tient à
un fait simple c'est que si bien sûr le
rassemblement national et avant front
national a manifestement développer des
idées auxquelles les gens adhèrent de
plus en plus c'est surtout des idées
pour des sur une analyse une analyse qui
date il ya déjà plusieurs années
comme cette analyse s'avère les faits
donnent raison
le bon sens de tout un chacun fait que
les os via nous suivre dans les
propositions que nous faisons est
aujourd'hui les propositions qui sont
faites sont véritablement la
concrétisation de tout ce que les gens
veulent voir réglé l'analyse parfois
fait mal mais il faut la voir avec
lucidité et il est urgent maintenant de
permettre la résolution des problèmes de
la vie quotidienne des français il reste
encore un petit peu temps il ya aussi la
confusion aussi sur les alliances entre
les républicains et la république en
marche qui vous est favorable selon vous
bien évidemment mais là aussi c'était
elles l'ont fait nos men qui est fait
que d'abord il ya un phénomène de base
sur les régionales comme toutes les
autres élections si cette notion des
deux tours les français ont vraiment
l'impression qu'au deuxième tour on leur
vole leurs votes de premier tour par des
alliances un peu contre nature
l'actuellement il apparaît avant
l'élection ses alliances qui sont des
magouilles des cafouillages de deuxième
tour ordinairement les français vraiment
sont là c'est tout ça et ils veulent en
changer et on va parler très brièvement
10 secondes de la présence d'un ministre
dans le nord oui bah écoutez ce
gouvernement est là aussi la
concrétisation de contorsions politique
pour essayer de récupérer 4 voir les
français n'en veulent plus véritablement
cette éthique
merci beaucoup je suis désolé de vous
couper la parole au moins on est
en règle avec le cssa ce matin on va
revenir à la politique française avec
évidemment cette marche
cet après midi à 13h justement pour
soutenir les policiers on l'a vu ça ne
fait pas l'unanimité notamment chez la
france insoumise
les policiers également on réagit
regarder et puis on en parle après il
vient apporter son soutien aux policiers
que nous représentons il ne vient pas
faire un meeting politique
c'est un rassemblement de policiers
citoyens il ya des endroits où des
meetings pour aller défendre ses
opinions
il est hors de question qu'un parti face
de la récupération sur le dos des
policiers
tous les autres partis seront présents
avec des figures un des partis qui
seront présentes à cette manifestation
que pensez vous de cette récupération
politique est ce que c'est le cas
notamment pour le rassemblement national
alors il est clair que les policiers ils
me disent que c'est une manifestation de
revendication
il est de la charge des politiques
d'entendre les revendications et il est
la charge des politiques au pouvoir de
faire en sorte que ces revendications
soient résolus et en tout cas que l'on
puisse apporter des solutions efficaces
aux demandes des policiers donc ce n'est
pas de la récupération politique au sens
où il s'agit d'un soutien pour dire que
certains politiques entendent mais au
delà d'entendre et c'est le cas du
rassemblement national malheureusement
je ne peux pas y être
il y aura une forte délégation de
parlementaires pour écouter les
policiers à la clé il y aura les
propositions nous attendons la même
chose de monsieur darmana et de monsieur
dupont moretti
juste un exemple rapide à titre
personnel je suis stupéfait on va voir
fréquenter les tribunaux pendant 30 ans
par mon boulot que l'on n'ait vu parce
que trois jeunes gens menacés des juges
qu'on ait vu les tribunaux venir petit à
petit des forteresses alors qu'il aurait
suffit simplement d'appliquer la loi
pour que les jeunes gens se calment et
là on est dans une reculade permanente
c'est ce que disent les policiers
au delà du phénomène relativement récent
qui est là des considérations
des forces de police qui elle fonctionne
malgré tout toujours en manque de moyens
matériels en matière humains et
maintenant des moyens sécuritaires c'est
quand même extraordinaire qu'on doive
protéger la police
nous sommes dans une inversion des
valeurs le soutien des politiques qui ne
sont pas au pouvoir est absolument
nécessaire
en revanche ceux qui sont au pouvoir
doivent régler la situation
alors le meilleur de l'intérieur l'union
sera présent comment est-ce que vous
analysez cette présence immédiate à un
ministre de l'intérieur à une marche
pour les policiers
est-ce que c'est sa place selon moi
selon moi non bien évidemment
mais les politiques au pouvoir depuis
déjà vingt ou trente ans n'ont rien
compris du rôle régalien qu'ils avaient
ce rôle régalien suppose que l'on prenne
de la hauteur et que l'on met en place
tout ce qui est nécessaire pour que les
la vie quotidienne des français et des
agents de l'état puisse se faire dans
des conditions tout à fait acceptable ce
n'est plus le cas il a et les fêtes de
aussi c'est que quand vous ne traitez
pas les causes en particulier la montée
de la délinquance sur fond de trafic de
drogue
sur fond de trafics illégaux de toutes
sortes et bien évidemment les problèmes
récurrents cuisson les arrivées de
migrants qui viennent pour des raisons
économiques ils ne viennent pas pour des
raisons de travail véritablement avec
les années sur 20 ans 30 ans 40 ans on
arrive à une situation inextricable
le ministre de l'intérieur qui est
présent et tolérée mais pas le garde des
sceaux quel message ça envoie un
ministre de l'intérieur dans une
manifestation et un garde des sceaux lui
qui est tenu à l'écart si c'est ces jeux
là on fait tout faux depuis le départ
encore une fois ils ne sont pas le place
ils n'ont pas compris leur rôle quand on
prétend à des de responsabilité comme
les leurs on prend la mesure de ce qu'il
faut faire et ne pas faire
ils sont comme s'il était toujours en
campagne comme s'il était toujours là
pour se faire réélire au motif qu à un
moment donné ils ont décroché la timbale
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe si
vous êtes élu c'est pour faire le
travail avec la hauteur nécessaire
la puissance nécessaire l'utilisation
des lois nécessaires
on le voit bien en termes actuellement
de judiciaire puisque c'est la sécurité
du judiciaire qui pose un problème
immédiat est bien c'est que les lois
aucun petit billet en tout cas main dans
la main
vous n'allez pas vous contredire vous
qui avez justement c'est évident mais
entre nous soit dit tout cela est du
théâtre et du théâtre re tcc des portes
qui claquent mais ça ne résout rien les
policiers afghans bien autre chose que
des effets de manche
alors on n'est pas mort et il n'est plus
n'est plus avocat une étude en les
effets de manche on a vu des violences
encore contre des policiers à argenteuil
avant-hier il ya des violences contrôler
les citoyens également un adolescent de
17 ans tu n as à champigny sur marne
hier quand est-ce que ça va s'arrêter
selon vous ça s'arrêtera quand on aura
des politiques qui ont pu la main qui
tremble
ils sont pas toujours dans l'idée de se
faire réélire avec des élections qui
sont de plus en plus nom signifiant il
faut tendre la mesure véritablement
appliqué la loi autant que faire se peut
et ne pas véritablement avoir tout ce
système à la fois policiers et surtout
judiciaires parce que tous les policiers
vous le diront c'est au niveau des
tribunaux qui lie à un engorgement la
joie je vous le dit tout à l'heure
les tribunaux sont bookés risée dans la
peur de faire venir des délinquants mais
aurait temps où est ton et il faut
véritablement que tout reprenne sa place
et que les juges travaillent pour
certains avec plus de moyens parce
qu'ils sont tout à fait des bouées à
leur cause et d'autres peut-être pense
que la neutralité est une nécessité
aussi quand on est un agent de l'état et
applique les pannes
après bien évidemment il ya les prisons
qui doit suivre l'application des peines
pour les jeunes gens parce que
maintenant à ce problème des très très
jeunes qui sont maintenant très violent
tout se passe comme si une partie de la
population ne voulait pas admettre qu'il
existe un code pénal dans notre pays
mais ces jeunes dont il
les fait référence évidemment à la mort
de cette jeune fille poignardée par à
ivry sur seine par un jeune de 14 ans il
ne connaît pas la loi la peur delà de la
peine de la sanction lourde et elle est
l dissuasive selon vous dans ce cas de
figure
je voudrais qu'on écoute la mère de
marjorie justement cette jeune fille de
17 ans qui a été poignardé on en parle
après prenez vos responsabilités
c'est à nous de faire l'éducation de nos
enfants on dirais qu'aujourd'hui
certains parents on dirait qu'ils
baissent les bras
c'est quelque chose que j'ai beaucoup de
mal à comprendre j'ai cinq enfants mais
j'ai toujours essayé de leur inculquer
des valeurs stricte les études d'abord
j'étais très à cheval sur ça je voulais
que chacun de mes enfants sortent de son
parcours scolaire avec un diplôme avec
quelque chose je me suis toujours battu
pour ça l'éducation et le respect cette
maman soulève un autre problème
évidemment qui a abouti à la violence de
ce jeune adolescent de 14 ans au delà de
la réponse policière il ya une autre
réponse à apporter mais comment faire au
niveau des départs en il y adeux une les
deux réponses
les deux réponses elles sont en partie
sur les parents bien entendu puisque
c'est on va dire actuellement 50% d'avis
d'un enfant du moins jusqu'à ce qu'on
estime être sa majorité et l'autre
partie c'est l'enseignement national il
y à déjà très longtemps j'avais été
frappé par des études de pédiatres dit
alors puis de 20 ans parlant de la
violence des jeunes gens et même
maintenant de plus en plus jeunes parce
qu' il existe avec des réseaux sociaux
avec l'ordinateur avec tout ce qui est
moyen moderne une espèce de maturité
nouvelle qui se créent et qui n'est pas
que les jeunes gens ne peuvent pas ou il
est même les adolescents que jeunes ne
peuvent pas assumer véritablement et
leur seule façon de répondre à cet
apprentissage de la connaissance
accéléré sous son aspect généralement le
plus violent les vents violents
donc il y allait de côté et là les
parents effectivement ne sont pas
soutenues il faut peut-être revoir à la
fois la place
parents complètement dans le cursus
peut-être faire en sorte qu' il y est
tout un système d'accompagnement mais
aussi au niveau des scolaires avoir des
programmes qu'ils soient mieux adaptés
on l'a prouvé que la méthode globale par
exemple rendent et violent c'est comme
ça c'est prouvé maintenant même semi
globale ça déclenche des phénomènes qui
sont des phénomènes non adaptés à la vie
de tous les jours
au delà de ça il y à une facture de
société véritable entre le laisser les
commandes il est entre les générations
roche ou achèter au vu des parents qui
étaient des parents tout à fait
méritante qui s'étaient battus venir
demander des retraites de 20 euros de
plus par mois alors que les enfants
gagner cent fois plus au bas de
l'immeuble
le même jour donc il y a des fractures
de société qu'il faut reprendre en main
et à les revoir plan sociologique
pourquoi dans entre autres dans les
zones qui sont violentes et où il ya
moins de travail
on pourrait faire une alternative à
l'argent facile vous êtes député
européen on va parler de cette crise
migratoire
huit mille clandestins arrivés à ceuta
du maroc le chef du gouvernement
espagnol a été hué à son arrivée hier
sur cette enclave espagnole par les
habitants on l'entend justement n'est
pas pour pour son inaction une grave
crise pour l'espagne une grave crise
pour l'europe a dit pedro sanchez
où en est l'europe sur la question
migratoire est alors là elle est
complètement à contre-courant de ce
qu'il faudrait faire
au motif que l'on aurait des frontières
extérieures mais les champs découvre que
ces huttes à mellila mais aussi
différentes ils sont aussi des
frontières extérieures de l'europe et
que ces enclaves en pays étrangers on
sait que l'espagne et le maroc où une
longue histoire autour de ces enclaves
vient public il n'y a absolument pas les
moyens pour empêcher des flux
migratoires lors ce sont toutes ces
filières de la méditerranée que l'on
voit que l'on voit pas selon que lui il
ne s'active pas lampée de mu à l'espagne
et la
est ce ça met le focus et l'europe au
contraire fait un plan migratoire qui va
à linverse il est clair que le but de
tout ça c'est pas du tout innocente
il faut savoir que le but de tout ça est
quand même la volonté politique de tirer
les salaires vers le bas en pensant que
cette immigration sera une immigration
de travail
or les données actuelles prouve que non
cela débouche sur des déplacements de
populations qui sont bien entendu
arrachés à leurs traditions ordinaire et
ne trouve pas du travail ou ne veulent
pas en trouver parce que pour revenir à
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure il
ya maintenant totalement d'économie
parallèle où l'argent facile est
beaucoup plus simple que celui qui
travaille
sachant que de toute façon il y a une
grande modification à l'heure actuelle
des paradigmes du travail avec les
plateformes numériques
le coc vie de leur a accéléré on sait
très bien qu'il ait plus en plus
difficile d'être salariés les plus en
plus difficile d'avoir un cdi
il est de plus en plus difficile d'être
formé l'europe elle ne prend pas la
mesure de ce qu'il faudrait faire
et l inverse elle accélère un phénomène
qui va déboucher sur des conflits est
tout à fait anormal qu'une fois de plus
le maroc et l'espagne et peut-être même
le maroc et le reste de l'europe se
trouve en conflit alors que nous avons
toujours eue avec ce pays des relations
courtoises le problème le maroc aurait
utilisé cette arme de l'immigration en
représailles
à l'espagne qui avait accueilli un
membre du front polisario donc ça
devient aussi une arme diplomatique que
peut faire l'europe par rapport à ces
chantages l'europe c'est de ne pas
permettre une immigration à partir de
l'ipad chanteuse je crois qu'il vaut
mieux traiter les causes que les
conséquences voilà quant à cette
enclaves de ceuta
je suis allé regarder un peu plus parce
qu'évidemment je la connaissais que de
nom
c'est quand même une enclave où il ya
4500 personnes km² je vous rappelle
qu'en suède y en a 23
donc on est dans des zones déjà de
surpopulation sont les zones de transit
économique et au delà de ça dès
l'instant qu'on vient transporté en pays
étranger les causes internes c'est un
petit peu ce qui se passe avec israël et
la palestine
on prend des grands risques et les
l'europe en permettant ces plans
migratoire importe aussi au delà
d'importer les personnes et c'est celle
là qui courbent puisque il ya l'humain
qui court du bien entendu mais au delà
d'eux portait le laisser venir des
personnes importe les conflits porté par
ces personnes
savidan tendue c'est une faute politique
merci beaucoup joëlle melin d'avoir
répondu en direct ce matin à nos
questions sur rtl france